the Golden Globes let's talk about that
you get to go to the Golden Globes you
made like a long well it's the table
that I was at I was I was right in the
front and at my table were Ryan Gosling
and yeah and Brad Pitt and Christian
Bale and right across from me was
Harrison Ford oh my god
POTUS and his lovely wife Calista
Flockhart and it was like this
incredible table is that one of those
moments where you're sitting there and
you're thinking cuz that's the classic
thing to think is you're a big a-list
star but you're sitting you're thinking
like oh my god how did I end up at the
Golden Globes at this table in totally
yes totally it was why it was really why
the hell am I at this table that's right
that's what you were alluding to didn't
know but the difference is when I'm at a
table like that people say why the hell
are you at this table and then they
motion to guard and I'm taken away
that's exactly how I felt like I didn't
and you don't want to engage Harrison
Ford in conversation because he's
Harrison Ford yeah you don't want to
bother Harrison Ford I'm not gonna ask
Harrison Ford for a selfie right and he
said a couple of things to me and I just
went yeah you got to be careful what if
he'd said I hear you'll have a criminal
record yeah it's true
No so cool so nice yeah did you feel
like we were able to be unselfconscious
and just enjoy the evening not at all
yeah no because there's always a camera
somewhere in the room trained on you so
if you bat an eye they will be picking
it up so right if you do the wrong thing
no you plaster a smile on your face and
and you just look like you're enjoying
base they serve a good good thing they
don't do an in memoriam yeah that one
yeah Carell everyone's dead do you find
cuz they eat as her food served food is
served I would be afraid to eat I'm
sometimes I get because I'm Irish
Catholic and grew up that way I get
really into the food like eat it quickly
my brothers might get it there'd be lots
of shots of me just plowing into food
yeah you don't yeah you don't want to be
caught on camera with it but actually
they had there was food before the
ceremony on each table were the
beautiful boxes of chocolates so my wife
Nancy and I decided to go for the
caramels yeah and they were super chewy
yeah we're coming back from commercial
and we're going we could be a caramel
stuck up in our teeth and couldn't get
it out so I'm going I was watching I
thought you guys had chewing tobacco
yeah I guess the tools